buckle up girls there's a sexy new
singer in town and guess what he just
turned 13 there's only a music video I
want to marry you at recess has racked
up 22 million views in just three days
some in the music industry are already
calling him the next big white kid and
that's why we are so lucky to have him
in the studio with us today for his
first ever live TV interviewees welcome
chase dreams and his mother passed today
you so much for having us well of course
so walk us through this okay
did you always want to be a famous
singer um I actually never really sang
before I just made this one video for
fun and I guess lots of people like this
yeah they sure did so mom does this kind
of talent run in the family you have
other kids right yes his older brother
Carrie is an actor here in New York City
he's really good Wow what kind of work
does he do hi I'm Carrie dubeck and I'm
reading for the role of man at party who
smells fart great party thank you okay
great let's go again but this time I
think the fart is just bigger and better
does that make sense
yeah okay you're only 13 years old
it's incredible to be so talented it's
such a young age
well actually Kathie Lee that's kind of
normal in our family my oldest Brooke
was actually a professional dancer when
she was chases age that's me so what's
she doing now
[Music]
look what are you doing up here
cuz I'm ready to show this apartment to
global bio fund LLC you have to tell us
how did you come up with that fantastic
name chase dreams ray you love that well
I actually have that phrase on a
decorative rock in my bathroom of course
you do but it also means like how it's
important to chase dreams Wow like
literally my family taught me that how
you gotta live life to the forest cuz
you never know when it's all gonna be
over so you just gotta chase dreams
[Music]
you